- Thanks. I'm gonna draw together some of
what my colleagues today have said
and then some of what we heard yesterday,
especially in the session on climate.
I'm going to talk briefly, I think,
about kind of the underlying, you know,
kind of essence and characteristics
of what we call the global nuclear order.
And then I'm going to try to explore
what I think are some of
the, again, deeper causes
of the disorder that my
colleagues have talked about.
And then, briefly suggest
some things that can be done,
that kind of build on or add
to what they had talked about.
Michael, you know, began by talking about,
in essence, you know, at
least one of the pillars
of what became a global
nuclear order after 1945.
And he talked about how remarkable it is
that nuclear weapons hadn't been detonated
in anger against targets since 1945.
And I think that's the essence
of the accomplishment of the nuclear war,
but there were additional facets to it.
There was a tremendous worry
that nuclear weapons would
proliferate to other countries.
So, famously, President
Kennedy's administration,
President Kennedy was briefed
that 25 countries would
acquire nuclear weapons
very quickly, very soon if
things continued as they would.
And, so for a variety of reasons,
particularly the US and the Soviet Union
cooperated to create the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty,
and that was negotiated, finally, in 1968.
And, basically, since then,
since that treaty was done and
entered into force in 1970,
there's only been one country
that signed the treaty,
then cheated on it and
acquired nuclear weapons,
and that's North Korea.
It's quite a remarkable achievement.
If you think about international treaties,
you think about anything,
you think about domestic
legislation and crime,
and to have, you know, that rate,
that small rate of violation, you know,
that somebody gets away
with, is quite remarkable.
And, so, that was another element
of this global nuclear order.
And then, the third element of it
was peaceful cooperation
and atomic energy.
So if you think about it,
and I'm going to come to this later,
because today nuclear
energy isn't very attractive
except in a few non-market
societies or economies
but there are lots of,
I should know how many nuclear
power plants in the world,
but it's around 450 thereabouts
and in many countries,
and that operation has gone relatively,
well it's gone very well
in terms of people cheating
and building nuclear weapons
out of those civilian nuclear programs.
And that was another part
of this nuclear order that was created.
And, I guess what I want to say about it,
it's been a remarkable success
and it's what was key to it,
is it's built on reliable reciprocity.
That's an expression that I
borrowed from Lauren Berlant,
who is a, she's like a literary theorist
at the University of Chicago,
that I had never heard
of until two weeks ago
and then I checked out
a book that she wrote
and a lot of it's hard to read
but then there's some really
brilliant stuff in it too
that I can understand.
And one of these,
and I used to talk about
sustainable reciprocity,
but she has reliable reciprocity,
which is alliterative,
and it's just great.
So, I stole it and I'll quit
footnoting it hereafter,
but that's what it was built upon,
that if you restrain yourself,
if the weapon States
restrained themselves,
if they agree to work
towards nuclear disarmament
and others restrain themselves
from acquiring nuclear weapons
and you play by the rules,
everybody does better through
that kind of reciprocity.
And it's some of what we
talked about yesterday
and other elements of multilateralism,
it's central to multilateralism.
It was key to the nuclear order working,
as I said, the non-proliferation treaty
was the essence of it
and so here I'll borrow
from something Kevin Rudd said last night
about the UN, which was based-
he said, look if the UN didn't exist
we'd have to invent something like it.
Well, if the non-proliferation
treaty didn't exist
we'd have to invent something like it,
except today it will be
much, much harder to invent
and get international
subscription for than it was then.
So in many ways, it's
all the more important to
to defend and to invest in restoring.
And the last point to,
again, set the stage
about order and how important
the order is in here,
in here I'm picking up on something
Professor Yan said, which is,
look at how we're worried
about artificial intelligence today,
cyber more broadly, but
artificial intelligence,
especially, has people very concerned.
Whether it's automated weapons
systems, you know, aircraft,
everything people are worried about,
especially the international dimension.
And there is no order there.
There's no domestic regulation,
there's no understanding
of liability domestically.
Internationally, they haven't
even begun discussions of it.
And so, when you think,
you juxtapose that kind
of nascent stage of technology burgeoning,
lots of concern about it,
there's a sense that
it needs to be ordered.
No one has the slightest idea
how it's going to be done.
Well, that was kind of
where nuclear began in 1945
and so it's quite remarkable how quickly
and successfully an order
was built in that domain.
And we should hope that we can figure out
how to do as well with AI and
some of these technologies.
But if that's going to be the case,
I think we're going to have to go back
to the fundamental principles
of reliable reciprocity, quid pro quos,
and creating incentives
for people to comply.
So, that leads me to the second section,
which is, my sense that,
that what we're experiencing
in a lot of the problems
that people here talked about,
whether it's the INF treaty
being first violated,
and then, you know, withdrawn from,
the absence of arms
control, the DPRK challenge,
the Iran undoing, there's
a long list, the arms race.
I think what's happening,
is you have disinvestment
from this nuclear order,
and disinvestment from at
least two blocks of country.
And I'll suggest, there are
four factors driving it.
So the US, and I would say, Russia,
are disinvesting from that nuclear order
for somewhat similar reasons.
The US disinvestment is really intensified
and made explicit by John
Bolton and President Trump.
But really, John Bolton makes it explicit.
And the idea is, look,
there aren't many threats
of proliferation anymore.
All right, like name the
country that we're now worried
about will acquire nuclear weapons.
The one that people
nominate is Saudi Arabia.
Well, first of all, from
the Bush administration
that isn't the biggest
problem in the world.
So then, the next thing is, well okay,
so, tell me a bad guy
who's going to get nuclear weapons now.
And the answer of, I'm sorry,
of the Trump administration
and John Bolton is we'll handle
that ourselves, militarily.
So, we don't need all these rules
and this rigmarole and all these bargains
and concessions and
trade-offs, you know, screw it.
If somebody does it, we'll remove them
and that was basically the
Bush administration strategy
in 2002, with the axis of evil.
That's the strategy
that led to the invasion
of Iraq and Iran was supposed to be next,
you know, or North Korea.
And so, the approach is you don't,
it's like the NRA says about arms control,
the problem isn't arms,
it's not nuclear arms.
The problem is bad guys with nuclear arms
and so the strategy is
not to control the arms,
it's to get rid of the bad guys.
And so, it's a coherent theory
that leads to disinvestment
from that kind of order,
and I think Russia is disinvesting
for somewhat related reasons.
Russia is more concerned about
selling nuclear power plants,
about making deals in countries
that may be seeking to
acquire nuclear energy.
And if there's a worry
that those countries,
like Saudi Arabia, may seek
to acquire nuclear weapons,
we'll deal with that later,
or that will be the US's problem
or somebody else's problem,
but it's not the first concern.
And beyond sales, the bigger concern
is contesting and countering the US
and trying to play off
challenges with other countries
as a way to gain leverage over the US.
I think the second factor
causing disinvestment
is that nuclear energy
is no longer attractive.
It's not attractive enough
for developing countries to make them go,
gee, I want nuclear energy so badly,
that I'll do whatever these
people are telling me to do,
in terms of export controls,
not acquiring nuclear
weapons, behaving well,
so that I can get nuclear energy.
Look at it now and I'd
say after Fukushima,
especially, but also just prices,
it's just not a great investment.
China's the only country, really,
that's got a kind of,
a still a burgeoning
nuclear energy program.
And so, I think that changes the dynamic
within the nuclear order.
The third, kind of,
disinvesting, you know,
dynamic is that the
disadvantaged participants
in this order, are ones
that feel they're victims,
are primarily the
non-nuclear weapons States.
The countries in South America, Africa,
and parts of Asia that
feel they get no benefit
from nuclear deterrence.
All right.
So, you know, unlike our NATO allies,
US-NATO allies, unlike Russia,
these countries go look,
we don't face threats
for which nuclear deterrence is relevant.
These countries aren't gonna defend us.
And yet, if they have a big
nuclear war, we get screwed.
Like, our food supply is
going to be endangered.
We are going to be dealing
with the global chaos
that will come with that.
And so, they say, we want
to morally protest this,
we want to disinvest and
challenge this system.
And so, they basically led
negotiation two years ago
of a treaty to prohibit nuclear weapons.
All right.
Frustrated with the
non-proliferation treaty,
feeling that the nuclear weapons states
are never going to get
rid of nuclear weapons.
They said to hell with it, we'll just,
we'll negotiate a separate treaty,
that'll just ban them,
prohibit them, period.
It doesn't matter if it's not binding
on any of the weapons states,
we'll make our stand on there.
And we're less interested
now in non-proliferation.
I think the fourth driver
of this disinvestment
is something that we've
been talking about,
which is new technology.
So, whether it's artificial intelligence,
hypersonic conventional weapons,
that Nikolai talked about,
other kinds of systems,
people are kind of going,
those are the new threats
that we really gotta be worried about.
Nuclear is kind of the old,
it's not clear how nuclear arms control
and the existing systems going to deal
with these new technologies.
So, let's focus on the new technologies
and spend less time and
energy on the old ones.
So, from different directions,
you've got some people arguing from, like,
a security narrative saying
they're disinvesting,
others from a moral or
humanitarian narrative
saying they're disinvesting
from this order.
And all of that is compounded
by the lack of leadership from the US
because new orders, basically,
whether they're trained, as
we talked about yesterday,
or climate and nuclear, you need at least,
like one of the biggest
powers to try to drive it,
preferably you'd have two.
So the nuclear war was built by the US
and the Soviet Union, we talked yesterday,
Todd talked about, you can't do climate
without the US and China.
I would argue, I mean, both
of those things are true
and on the nuclear, we're
going to have to have the US,
Russia, and China going forward.
If you don't have that cooperation
you can't, basically, you
know, restore the order.
So that leads to what can we do about it?
In my mind, you know, the first thing is
something that none of
my colleagues think about
and that Washington
doesn't think about at all.
Except maybe President Trump
and this is a serious comment,
and kind of praise of him.
It's not praise, but it's an accident,
but how do you get Russia
off the sanctions track?
So Russia had a bunch of
sanctions imposed deservedly,
in my view, for what it did in Ukraine.
But the problem with sanctions
is once you've applied them
you've kind of defeated the purpose,
the behavior that you
are trying to change,
you know, doesn't work.
So in Russia's case,
how do we move forward?
How does the world move forward?
Russia is never giving back Crimea.
I mean, never is a long time.
It's not clear when and why
Russia would give back Crimea.
It's still meddling in Ukraine.
The sanctions are there.
Putin is really pissed off about it.
He wants the sanctions removed.
There's no dialogue or
even thinking in the west,
how to remove the sanctions.
And so if you want to get
Russia to come back in
and play on these other issues,
how do you motivate them to do that?
Seems to me a vital issue
that no one's really thinking about.
And then with China,
how do you deal with the
territorial aggrandizement
that has people so concerned
in the South China seas?
There's a building of islands
out of rock outcroppings
or adding of runways
on to things that alarm
ASEAN States, Japan, the US, and others.
We have to deal with the-
And then China's concerned
about what US intentions are in Taiwan.
If you don't address
those underlying issues.
It seems to me it's very hard to then get
into a serious discussion
about strategic stability
and tempering or controlling the military,
including the nuclear competition.
But again, we don't have a dialogue
with China on strategic stability.
We don't, we're not
engaged in that process.
And that was a problem before
the Trump administration
and it's been exacerbated by Trump.
So I've got a list of other things
that are very similar
to what came up in the climate discussion
about accountability and equity.
So there are larger
things than arms control
but it seems to me if
we don't address those,
the multilateral order
around nuclear weapons
is going to continue to
experience disinvestment.
And so I'll stop there.
- [Announcer] Okay. Thank you.